this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies we had a hundred thousand
subscribers what I can't believe that
many people were like yeah I'll watch
some more of this guy thank you all so
much for watching
let's celebrate the sheer size of a
hundred thousand is demanding a scale
video a while back I did one with the
earth and the moon at a scale of fifty
two million eight hundred thousand to
one the earth and the moon were the size
of a basketball and a tennis ball but
why stop there
rule number four here in the asylum is
go big or go home let's take one more
step out and do the entire solar system
but just to keep things interesting
let's lay down some ground rules one
will be using the same scale we used in
the Earth Moon video fifty two million
eight hundred thousand two one two for
each astronomical object there will also
be a normal sized object just like the
earth in the moon or a basketball in a
tennis ball will be doing the same for
all the other planets and the Sun three
both the size of the objects and the
distances between them will be to the
same scale I'm gonna need some adventure
clones for this
[Music]
go go go go go places the beat go the
natural place to start a solar system
video is with the Sun that yellow white
star at the center of the solar system
it contains ninety-nine point eight
percent of the solar system's mass for
some perspective let's say the mass of
the solar system is a thousand dollars
the Sun will be nine hundred and ninety
eight of those dollars which leaves only
two dollars for everything else the Sun
is in control it's also really big eight
hundred and sixty four thousand three
hundred and thirty seven miles across
that's a little over a hundred and nine
Earth's just across its diameter in
terms of volume its 1.3 million Earth's
that's big
does that mean you need to find an
object that's a hundred and nine
basketballs across yep and I have just
the thing just outside Detroit in Allan
Park Michigan there's a giant tire
that's exactly the right size like an
actual tire made of rubber it was made
for the 1964 New York World's Fair to be
a ferris wheel if you don't believe me
here's a picture from the brochure this
tire is 85 feet or 26 meters across
which is the perfect size for our scale
a hundred and nine basketballs across
seriously that's one of my adventure
clothes right there it's the perfect
launch point for an insane scale model
of the solar system the closest planet
to the Sun is mercury which is about the
size of a softball on our scale it's
pretty small compared to that giant tire
and probably farther away than you're
thinking on a map it's about 0.68 miles
or 1.1 kilometers from the scaled Sun a
distance easily walked by one of my
adventure clothes here
you can see the tire without any trouble
the Sun is still rather large in the sky
at this distance Mercury's orbit is
pretty eccentric though so that point
six eight miles is just an average it's
point five four miles at closest and
point eight two miles at farther
that has dramatic effects on what the
Sun looks like in the sky over the
course of Mercury's year for comparison
here's what the Sun looks like from
Earth next up Venus it's about the size
of a soccer ball on our scale on the map
Venus is about 1.3 miles or 2.1
kilometers away from the scaled Sun
which passes through a shopping center
known to locals as the hill that 1.3
miles is a sizable distance from the
giant tire we're using as our Sun you
can't see the tire anymore but that's
only because there's stuff in the way
none of that stuff is part of our model
though in space we'd have a clearer view
and could still see the Sun in the
distance you might have noticed that a
soccer ball is only a little bit smaller
than a basketball which means Venus is
about the same size as Earth so it
shouldn't be any surprise it's sometimes
called Earth's sister planet and it's
our closest neighbor but not this close
that would be both terrifying and
apocalyptic
on are scaled map the earth and Venus
are actually about a half a mile apart
to scale these two objects are half a
mile apart that puts the earth an
average of about 1.8 miles are 2.9
kilometers from the scaled Sun the best
location it passes through is Beaumont
Hospital in Dearborn that looks
something like this again the giant tire
is blocked by things like buildings but
with a clearer view you could still see
it in the distance from the surface of
the earth the Sun only spans about half
a degree in the sky but so does the moon
which is what makes total solar eclipse
as possible speaking of the moon I
mentioned earlier it was the size of a
tennis ball on our scale but not this
close to the earth the tennis ball needs
to be 24 feet or seven point three
meters from the basketball and then
orbit around it every 27 days now for
the last of the inner planets Mars it's
about the size of this hamster ball on
our scale probably the most obsession
inducing planet in human history we've
sent multiple probes we've seen faces
that weren't there back in the day
people were convinced there were canals
on the surface we'd even like to
colonize it someday it's in the
Goldilocks zone like Earth so that's not
out of the question
milton can tell you all about it really
all right
Mars orbits the scaled Sun at a distance
of two point seven miles or 4.3
kilometers which conveniently passes
through the parking lot of the Henry
Ford Museum you can actually tour the
museum in Google Streetview
there's some pretty cool stuff in there
you know if you like museums
here's our scaled Mars at that location
an average human on smooth ground can
see about three miles in any direction
so the scaled Sun should be just barely
on this side of the horizon from the
surface of Mars that's only point three
five degrees in the sky
okay so we've reached the edge of what
we call the inner solar system these are
the inner planets Mercury Venus Earth
and Mars they're tiny in comparison to
that giant tire we're using as our Sun
and they all orbit within three miles of
the Sun
on the map we define the distance from
the earth to the Sun to be one
astronomical unit or au that puts the
entire inner solar system well within
two au the outer planets are a different
story altogether we don't reach another
planet until a little over five au this
is where Jupiter orbits it's big and
it's massive you remember the thousand
dollars that represents the mass of the
solar system the Sun was 998 dollars
leaving only two dollars for everything
else
Jupiter takes up almost an entire dollar
of that two dollars we have left so it's
really massive but it's also really big
size and mass are two different things
you can fit almost 11 earths across the
diameter of Jupiter that means you can
fit over 1,300 earths
inside the volume of Jupiter it's pretty
much maxed out in size though fun fact
if you added more mass to it it wouldn't
actually get any bigger
just denser if we scale that diameter
down Jupiter is still eight point seven
feet across that's a hundred and four
inches or 265 centimeters what did you
find that big well I I didn't but but
just imagine a giant round conference
table on the map Jupiter's orbit is
almost 9.2 miles or fourteen point seven
kilometres from the Sun and passes right
through Wayne State University in
downtown Detroit home to a lot of really
cool architecture and right next to the
Detroit Institute of Arts that big
conference table looks something like
this as usual we're including an
adventure clone for scale in space you
can see the Sun in the distance because
there's nothing in the way I mean human
eyes can see the Sun out to about 60
light-years but we have a problem with
our scale model at nine miles the giant
tire we're using for our scaled Sun is
below the horizon the Earth's curvature
has moved it out of our line of sight
next up Saturn on a map Saturn orbits at
over sixteen point eight miles or 27
kilometers that's ten au from the Sun
twice the orbit of Jupiter at this
distance said
Orbitz passes through Willow Run Airport
where you'll find the Yankee air museum
they've got a bunch of old planes and
airforce trinkets and stuff as you can
see this adventure clone had a really
good time did you make this crazy scale
model of the solar system just so you
could send an adventure clone to all
these cool places maybe anyway Saturn is
pretty big on our scale to about 7.2
feet or 220 centimeters that's a much
more reasonably sized conference table
but it's still big although its rings
make it look bigger than it is here's
our reasonably sized conference table
known as Saturn that's just the planet
though its rings stretch out to about
here you can fit over nine earths across
its diameter even more across the Rings
but in space Saturn is pretty lonely
when the Sun expands into a red giant we
should just move the earth there we can
orbit Saturn and have a view like this
every day they'd be pretty cool if you
ask me the next planet our is Uranus
which is about the size of this Hulu
it's still pretty big about 38 inches or
96 centimeters in diameter but at least
I have a real object this time that puts
its orbit out at 33.8 miles or 54.4
kilometers
almost twice the orbit of Saturn which
sends us orbit right through the
imagination station in Brighton it's the
coolest playground setup I've ever seen
this thing is huge
it's right next to a big pond too you
know if you like nature without too much
nature you can fit about 4 earths across
its diameter it's no wonder they call
these outer planets Giants it's actually
will appearance is pretty plain though
not a lot of cloud detail some might
even call it the most boring planet but
I think it's pretty cool that it rotates
on its side
that's an axial tilt of 98 degrees
there must be some weird seasons last
but certainly not least Neptune you can
see it's a little smaller than Uranus
but they're really far apart Neptune is
located a whopping 53 miles or 85
kilometers from the scaled Sun that's
about 30 au another 10 au Beyond Uranus
they're not kidding when they call these
outer planets on the map it passes right
through the Lost Railway Museum in Grass
Lake I know their Museum yeah I like
museums okay
anyway the museum is on the edge of
downtown Grass Lake right on Michigan
Avenue it's full of old rail cars and
stuff out back there are railroad tracks
which is a perfect location for an
adventure clone to hold the tube I mean
them too
it often has a dark storm with winds
approaching 1500 miles per hour that's
the fastest winds in the solar system
okay so we've reached the edge of what
we call the outer planets here they are
in all their glory Jupiter Saturn Uranus
and Neptune they're pretty big compared
to the inner planets but still small
next to the Sun remember our scaled Sun
is the size of this giant tire it's
clear from the sizes of their orbits why
we split the solar system in two but
there's even a physical division called
the asteroid belt that's not the only
place we find asteroids it's just an
interesting concentration of them we
find rocks of many sizes all over the
solar system most of them are comets in
the Kuiper belt a belt that includes
Pluto and the Oort cloud which stretches
out so far beyond the planets it's
difficult to even imagine this is the
limit of the sun's control any object
beyond that is closer to nearby stars
like alpha or beta Centauri than it is
to the Sun this is probably the biggest
scale we can use for the solar system
and still have the sizes of the objects
be reasonable so was that a crazy enough
solar system model for you let us know
in the comments and again thank you all
for continuing to watch my crazy face
the last couple of years have been quite
a trip also thanks for liking and
sharing this video don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little crazy
if you want to support my channel check
out my patreon if you haven't already
there's also a new YouTube feature
called channel memberships you just
click the join button to sign up I still
prefer patreon they have way more
features and they take a much smaller
cut but for those of you who don't like
it for whatever reason
here's your alternative anyway thanks
for watching